hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to leanie Boog if you
remember I played the demo this and
unlike most horror games that I play
this one had a full version released
that sounds mean to the other
um
I don't mean any discredit sometimes
demos happen and they don't turn into
full games that's just a fact I'm not
lying stop looking at me like that oh
God difficulty um let's do medium first
because I remember this game was kind of
difficult I don't know if it's going to
be in the exact same place highly
recommended not recommended to set the
volume high can hurt your ears well I'm
gonna do it anyway 10 years of playing
horror games and I'm pretty sure that I
can
I can take it that's how it works I
calloused my eardrums they're tough
like leather
again that doesn't sound good
[Music]
leanie Boog if I say it three times will
it summon the lean oh
this looks different
these aren't letters I remember oh
I didn't mean to do that
inspect the office yeah I will
okay again not really letters that I can
remember unless isn't the this isn't the
office that we're talking about here
okay
hello
has anybody seen an office oh I'm in an
office building
it's kind of different when I thought oh
really good at opening doors behind my
back
okay
foreign
[Music]
actually mean one or is that just
another symbol that I don't remember
well
this has been delightful
sure wish I could read anything that I
point my flashlight at okay apparently
all right find the noise Source I'll do
that
do that
okay
why why will how where where where how
and where and where and how close it
that's probably fine
I don't have anything to worry about
here
oh my God
well aren't you just delightful I can't
read that I don't know those words
according to our data subject Ava left a
certain envelope in the house the
contest of which are still considered
unknown
in addition we learned that the
attackers were committed the brutal
murder of a security guard in the
archive last week stole data about this
house
probably the attacker is also looking
for the top below
God damn why did Poison chair have to be
adjustable I don't like having a choice
I like getting used to the discomfort oh
this looks familiar your task is to
listen carefully to which part of the
house the monster is running to so you
can close a window in time close window
hold the E key turn up my volume
I know you said not to but I'm gonna do
no no no no no no no no no no no oh I
forgot I had to hold it
or maybe I pressed it twice I can't
remember what I did I am dead
thanks man
[Music]
gotta hold it in my hand
no
not today Mr
I'm not gonna get me that easy
you're gonna get me medium
I ordered
oh not today bookster
the no Boog house
anti-lean Squad here
[Music]
and tell me what that was do I want to
know what that was I don't want to know
what that was don't tell me what that
was
I don't want to know what anything is
ignorance is bliss
so
shut up
when you are predictable aren't you
why
I couldn't predict that
oh God upstairs
oh no
the bug
[Music]
is he gone
oh
hey boogie
okay so this is much like the demo
[Music]
[Music]
oh
God 360. 360 no lean
[Music]
that's too easy that's too easy Mr boog
it's too easy don't even try it
[Music]
the jumpy
oh what what oh what what
happened
the Boog the boo the Bride of the book
the boog
oh
he
he
[Music]
did
stupid
oh now the bird
oh there's nothing I can do about the
boob now
I didn't know that there
confusion hey TWA
hey hi hey boog
how you doing
how you doing you good good to hear
what's with this piping it's a heater
heating system of some kind I don't
really have an opportunity to ponder
what things are because I can't exactly
okay
[Music]
there's
oh that was him going back down
oh okay okay I'm good I'm good I'm good
I'm good okay
it's a little early
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right back upstairs
but that would have been what you wanted
[Music]
[Music]
I
hmm
like
oh not today not today
not today
okay all right why oh what
what does that mean
what did that mean did you break that
huh
what does that mean
what do they mean
oh I don't know what it meant
it seemed to come back alive though but
maybe it won't save when it's bro being
breached
I don't know what it meant I don't know
what meant
almost there
almost there just about a minute left
[Music]
plenty of time I got this in the bag me
and my medium ass
[Music]
foreign
music I'm assuming is good because that
I think that coincides with the game
being over
and me winning can't really hear him
though kind of a big move
I did it
I think
still don't know what that means
I could try to discern the meeting I
think it was five before
the father is currently away
as everyone knows representatives of the
brothers have a small stature things to
which the son of subject 88 men if they
leave without leaving any traces
after a third of the house the same
print was found within the infamous
archive
apparently it was the same killer
you're analyzing the phone calls we
found out that a certain citizen living
in the our tactical District called this
house the other day before our arrival
it was clear from the style of
communication that they knew each other
they were talking about the same
envelope that subject 88 left
at the end of the conversation they
agreed to me
I'm assuming that subject 88 is leanie
Boog but also that means that the father
and the son live at this house so does
that mean
17. got it does that mean that I am
either the father or the son of leanie
Boog I'm a Boog myself
I mean I seem to have a small stature
so
[Music]
17.
okay Papa it's me remember who you are
don't let the Boog consume you
hi friends
I really hope you have the envelope
your father risked everything to prevent
this envelope from falling into the
hands of the collection area or even
worse into the hands of the creature
that is now on your tail
don't worry he won't be able to get into
this apartment I've taken care of that
the most important thing to remember is
one thing do not open the envelope in
any case man I want to open the other
this can lead to sad consequences not
only for you but also for everyone
around you
have too little time and I have no right
to detain you
take this walkie-talkie that'll help you
from time to time thanks friend love
your buddy what is that supposed to mean
you can find a train ticket in the Next
Room it will take you to the right place
when you arrive at your destination I'll
contact you again
I ain't seeing no train ticket
I ain't seen no ticket oh this uh oh oh
oh
interesting
how fascinating
someone was a little Boog obsessed
what lovely pictures you got of the Boog
oh
so
I can't read that I don't know what
that's about
okay A little bloody oh
that didn't look like a train ticket
that looked like a cipher
o
even saying the names
well at least you could admit your own
faults so congratulations that's the
first step on the road to recovery what
am I doing
am I on the train your task is to
prevent the monster from entering the
compartment you to do this you need to
carefully monitor the movement of the
monster and close the door in the time
or exit the compartment in a timely
manner the compartment you will need to
enter will be highlighted to close the
door or exit the compartment you need to
press the key that appears on your
screen it is
impressively exported to monitor the
movement of the monster because
otherwise the key will not appear on
your screen
okay what are you talking about
compartments this train compartment or
the rooms in there the compartmentalized
rooms I guess I'll figure it out
interesting
interesting
interesting
interesting
what what is that about
what oh
what
what is happening what do I do oh no
what do I do
oh what have I done
I can't do anything but e and Q and I
picked the wrong compartment
oh
hi okay
[Music]
oh God
oh God
no no no no no no
okay but
am I doing this right I don't feel like
I'm doing this right
oh no
am I doing this right
I don't think I'm doing this right
but I seem to be not dying oh
oh uh I would love to press in anything
I would love to press literally anything
okay
what I am dead I don't know what I did
hang on okay to do the carefully monitor
the movement close the door in time or
exit the compartment ah
other way I need to exit it
see right so I was looking at it in the
window and that's not where I needed to
be I needed to be somewhere else
so
okay I guess here we go oh I'm going
back in
this is fine
[Music]
I'm gonna go now I'll leave goodbye okay
well that went well
go back in
yeah
you see
was that leanie boog
was that a boogie lean
[Music]
oh God oh God
okay goodbye
thank you for that thank you am I going
to run out of rooms here what happens to
the room that he uh goes into seems bad
news for me noted ho
ho has been noted
[Music]
you're making a habit of this and I
don't like it okay
oh ah I do get to go back
okay well this seems simple enough now
that I understand what's happening the
recipe is simple
[Music]
I was R before
well aren't you just a dick it was hard
before I guess it changes I guess I have
to pay attention to it
foreign
okay well uh F all right goodbye okay I
can do that that's fine I can make that
happen I will make it happen I will
press the right buttons when the time
comes
oh my God I thought he was behind me I
really did
f f f f
it's f
[Music]
if
he really wants to be on this left side
I'm not being tricked
it is gonna be different you dick
you dick
Roar
really rude
[Music]
okay I'm out of here with tea goodbye
okay just gotta keep this up for another
194 seconds that's fine
a little over three minutes
nothing
right back in the same one that don't
feel good but I'll do it
for you Mr boog
or should I say father
[Music]
tea good thing I'm stronger than this
Boog how dangerous are you really if me
probably a child
can defeat you
[Music]
okay and F goodbye thank you that was
quick but it's okay
handled 100 seconds left easy easy easy
man how much did I pay for this ticket
it's not worth it I know I got it for
free but still not worth it
[Music]
tea
I can't believe I have to look at the
keyboard every time but I just really
don't want to hit the wrong key right
now
[Music]
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine
if
thank you for turning the lights back on
before you attack that's very helpful
honestly I don't even know if it's
helpful but it feels helpful
no no no no no not now music not now
music
don't be like this
okay out and R oh my God Muse don't be
like this right now
I don't need this
okay
ah we made it to the destination someone
finally came to collect my ticket some
other human being was here
M1 M1
3
okay
further actions will be adjusted
depending on the circumstances
further actions sounds reliable and
lovely thank you my my worries are where
am I
my friend there's a security post here
right sure is how do you know how do you
know that again how do you know all of
these things it's a bit concerning that
you know these things
numbers
flashlight do you see the generator no
activating it will open a large gate
there won't be anyone inside I've taken
care of that
we can only hope that this creature has
lost you how are you taking care of that
the drawings indicate that four
generators will be waiting for you
inside after they are turned on the gate
to the disintegration room will open
you'll have to take this envelope there
and
after you go inside I won't be able to
help you anymore
you'll have to do everything yourself
disintegration
don't worry everything will be fine do I
have this envelope good luck buddy
thanks friend is this what you call a
generator call the lever
I don't think it's generating much maybe
transferring something three
[Music]
Boog take the large flashlight yes
please I'll take a large
Wham how do I turn this bad boy on WOW
can I turn it on spot out where's Boog
I'm gonna blind him
I guess I can't seems to be broken okay
I'll just head inside everything's fine
the last thing that I would do when a
Boog just approached would be try to
leave the building that the Boog tried
to get in your task is to activate four
generators after their activation the
big doors will open the only way to
survive when encountering the monster is
to shine a flashlight in his face turn
on the flashlight hold down the F key if
you release the flashlight button before
turning it on it will temporarily fail
so
you talking about
oh that's a little bit of a oh you
chewed up some batteries okay
well I need to find generators oh
okay one well that was easy
good thing this place isn't built like a
maze is it
booster
booster you hear booster
Boogeyman
Boogeyman
that makes sense
no
[Music]
not
that
nothing there's no Boog in here never
was all just a figment of my imagination
no boobs
no such thing
definitely not
oh oh oh so it's not an inch I got a
you didn't mention that in the
description you didn't you didn't
discuss that you didn't talk about that
couldn't have made it like you know the
click Mouse one couldn't have been you
know the Boog repellent kind of makes it
easier to walk around if I don't have to
Boo get up while I'm trying to backpedal
well I'm throwing that out there you
know you couldn't but you didn't but
whatever okay I'm gonna get everything
on this level before I go on to another
area that I don't know has anything
oh that's two hey good wow I love when I
do a 360 for those why is the music like
that why is the music going like that
why is the music going like that why
would the music go like that
why would the music be like that
yeah yeah
this boobster I had two does
I had two does fine
I'll do this myself
but now I'm definitely going to do it
myself
so when that music comes I'm just gonna
get in that long hallway because I need
a lead up
I need a lead up please
get get get go get what are you doing go
go get gone what do you do yeah that's
what I thought that's okay yeah you
better run yeah you better run
yeah that's what I thought that's what I
thought I don't know exactly what that
did for you but that's what I thought I
always thought that now I that's what I
thought
foreign
okay I don't know how long it takes them
to get back
oh that's probably not a good sound
that's probably not a good sound
[Music]
which way which way
sounds like a boob from over there
[Music]
big big
[Music]
that's what I thought that's what I
thought that's what I thought okay
oh I can run I forgot that that I can I
run backwards yeah I can okay okay good
good good good
thing this flashlight isn't bound to
Mouse one or something easy
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
hmm that doesn't sound good
I'll sure hope I don't get caught here
with my pants down
seems like I'm gonna get caught here
with my pants down
I don't really have anywhere to back up
oh
no not like this
yes no maybe so
[Music]
Oh Lordy coming okay God I wish this was
not bound to half
why the F would you be bound to f
right bookster
why would they find it I have another
mouse click where did he go did he go
this way oh those are the big doors okay
okay okay got it understood Roger that
hey boo listen I gotta go that way so uh
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God why why
okay I was about to say okay thank you
Boog but I also have to go that way so
if you could just go away forever that'd
be great
[Music]
okay one more and then I Boog them up a
little bit
and then boogs your uncle
well this is a nice convenient long
hallway
sure do like this
hope I don't get caught with my pants
down
oh God I'm gonna get caught with my
pants down oh God I'm gonna get caught
with my oh no here's common
oh Lord he's coming I'm just gonna wait
for him ever
that's a good idea
I should wait for my show I should go I
should wait
[Music]
yeah
it was the wrong move
can you please okay thank you
please please please
ah please okay that was the last one I
just gotta survive him uno mas
which I think I have the resources to do
that in my flashlight
so I'm going to do that
oh hey bud oh God oh God here we go here
we go here we go here we go here we go
oh God I gotta move my hand to navigate
around that corner okay hey bud hey bud
yeah yeah yeah
oh no my eyeballs whoa no life's so hard
for a furry like me oh no
oh God I don't know which way he's gonna
come from next time
okay well that's good
oh God where did he go oh no
oh no oh no
oh no
oh no he's gonna round one of these
corners
oh God
oh God okay you're fine we're fine
they're fine they're fine he's fine
it's fine
close the door or something close the
door why would you not close the door am
I gonna burn something
where what
what oh why
[Music]
that's me I'm your son
I sure can
Daddy
[Music]
brother
right that's how that works
oh
seems like you were doing that
[Music]
this is a choice
okay
had you
had you with me
[Music]
while that's a tempting offer
that's really tempting
um
[Music]
[Music]
well
oh but look he wants a hug
you know
I don't trust what's going on with all
that other stuff you seem like an
upstanding Boog and uh yeah come here
wrong give me a big old hug
I made the right choice
oh
am I the Boog now
I think I'm the Boog hey that's not so
bad but also I don't get to know what
the hell was happening I don't even know
if I would have known what the hell was
happening if anything else happened
interesting choice
uh maybe maybe trusting the thing that
it's been trying to kill me for so long
hmm I don't know whatever it seemed like
the more interesting one anyway so that
is leanie Boog obviously there's another
ending for uh going not that way into
leanie boog's open arms but I did get a
best friend so that's pretty cool you
can't say that would have happened with
the other one probably would have had to
like sacrifice myself to end the curse
of the Leaning book or something like
that yeah who wants any of that
so uh you guys can check it out for
yourself if you want to try the other
version there's probably also like
secret endings for doing it on Extreme
but that seems kind of tough and down to
the wire in terms of reaction time and
I'm not about that
like relaxing experience
pretty good I do like it it's more just
like a side show of different mechanics
but I mean that's all a game really is
right but I think that was cool
obviously it was made by one person and
I think for what they made it's a pretty
good experience so very fun thank you
everybody so much for watching Link in
the description if you want to play the
game for yourself and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
foreign
[Music]